merci merci bernard on est là sur un
sujet absolument majeur qui et comment
le seae transformer la relation entre
l'administration au sens large du terme
d'administration et puis les les
entreprises dans certains pays on
conseille dans notre pays en contrôle il
faut certainement trouver un juste
milieu
moi j'aimerais bien voir le témoignage
des chefs d'entreprises qui sont qui
sont ici jean-bernard felco vous est
peut-être pouvez-vous présenter votre
entreprise parler évidemment de vos
relations et des relations de cette
entreprise avec l'administration entendu
ans au sens large du terme
ce soit de l'inspection du travail ou
d'autres types d'administration de nous
dire comment vous souhaiteriez que cela
évolue
et puis plus largement d'ailleurs votre
opinion sur aujourd'hui les règles du
travail en france
merci beaucoup de nous donner l'occasion
aux chefs d'entreprise effectivement de
deux pays aujourd'hui sur un sujet aussi
complexe que celui ci à partir de puits
sont fondamentaux de quatre générations
d'hôteliers j'ai écrit avec mon épouse
en 2005 une société qui est aujourd'hui
propriétaire et gestionnaire d'un parc
d'une trentaine d'établissements quatre
et cinq étoiles majoritairement situés
dans paris intra muros
et puis dans la région languedoc
roussillon et 1 et en région parisienne
fort du travail acharné de nos 700
collaborateurs en dix ans donc on est
passé par tous les indiens j'y
reviendrai et je reviendrai juste après
nous réalisons aujourd'hui un chiffre
d'affaires d'un peu plus de 80 millions
d'euros annuellement et nous avons la
chance de réaliser un taux d'occupation
dans une merveilleuse économie est un
écosystème génial qui s'appelle le
tourisme 95 % taux d'occupation donc
chez nous il fait beau le ciel est bleu
et le soleil brille et tous les jours et
et et nous sommes persuadés que ça va
continuer cantonner des chiffres macro
et microéconomiques et relié au secteur
du tourisme et à l'arrivée massive des
touristes et ça me permettra de faire le
lien avec l'économie collaborative fin
fin 2014 nous avons été les premiers à
créer une joint devanture sino
françaises dans l'industrie hôtellière
avant accord hier et avant le gros du
lot fours nous associer avec un
partenaire chinois et déployer ensemble
200 hôtels dans le monde boutique design
hôtel avec la création d'une marque
qui porte une marque d'élégance à la
française et d'art de recevoir la
française donc nous avons connu dans
cette évolution
effectivement au cours des dix dernières
années de nombreuses étapes
nous étions 4 en 2005 puis il se passer
à 10 donc avec les premiers le premier
seuil puis à 50 puis à 100 puis à 200 il
ya 500 et nous approchons celui d'emile
donc effectivement on a on a vécu avec
cette évolution ce code ce code du
travail et la création d'un département
des ressources humaines et sociales les
embauches de consultant junior puis
senior puis une directrice des
ressources humaines et sociales et
autres
et franchement c'est à la fois génial
intellectuellement bien sûr mais quelle
perte de temps sur un certain nombre de
sujets il faut si on devait résumer je
pense tout ce qui a été dit ce matin est
ce que pense dans l'ensemble des chefs
d'entreprise c'est que ce truc là là je
l'appelle ce truc là parce que
effectivement il est incompréhensible ce
machin il est incompréhensible pour nous
on fait appel à des avocats alors c'est
super en fait travailler les avocats
donc ça ça coûte beaucoup d'honoraires
chaque année et tant mieux pour eux et
on est ravi de l'avoir à nos côtés mais
à chaque fois qu'on embauche
je vous promets qu'on est obligé de se
mettre à quatre deux présidents la
vice-présidente le directeur général la
drh pour dire enfin cvd ont fait 1 s'est
dit on prend comme en france où quelle
forme ce qu'elle sous quel type de
contrat etc
c'est devenu l'enfer c'est un enfer et
on se dit tout de suite bon alors lui ou
elle risque de partir à un moment donné
quels sont les risques inhérents à son
départ et lorsque l'on doit licencier
quelqu'un on se rappelle de vent on
appelle notre avocat on fait attention à
tout bref quand on doit se séparer d'une
personne ça arrive dans les entreprises
des personnes qui sont pas forcément
adaptés aux postes où une leçon
dont ceux dont on doit se séparer c'est
quoi c'est complètement infernale non
nous nous je pense qu'un certain nombre
de chefs d'entreprise propose de
simplifier on vit une inflation
législative qui est totalement infernale
une complice une complexification à leur
soi-disant de la simplification en fait
rien n'a jamais été aussi complexe pour
les entreprises en matière sociale est
plutôt que de faire 50 principe quand
j'ai entendu ce matin ou je sais pas
quoi parce que de toutes les façons
effectivement c'est le juge qui aura le
dernier mot d'ailleurs quand vous lisez
des jugements du tribunal du tribunal du
conseil de prud'hommes c'est très
marrant c'est l'entreprise et c'est le
rapport de force employeurs salariés
l'entreprise contre le salarié on peut
pas s'appeler un nom par un prénom et
une entreprise juste vous lisez tous les
jugements de prud'hommes
c'est l'entreprise contre l'entreprise
l'employeur le salarié l'employeur le
salarié cette note quand même une
véritable culture dans l'esprit d'aider
des personnes
aujourd'hui on a évidemment parmi nos
700 personnes des gens qui ne
travaillent plus qu'ils sont on y lit en
inaptitude et celles et ceux qui sont
dans la salle et qui sont chefs
d'entreprise qu'ils comprennent ce que
c'est que de reclasser un salarié en
inaptitude c'est l'enfer c'est tout
simplement l'enfer
effectivement quand on se retrouve aussi
avec des délégués du personnel ou avec
des représentants syndicaux dans notre
entreprise avec qui dans notre en
trouvez ça se passe toujours bien
d'accord quand on dialogue avec un
représentant syndical ou un salarié ça
se passe toujours super bien
simplement il vous dit oui en off et
brandon quand il ya la réunion et dhiba
et mais à la centrale on m'a dit dire ça
à centrale on va dire ça à la centrale
on m'a dit tiens ça donc en fait rien
n'avance et et c'est l'enfer dont contre
le ch était le comité d entreprise tout
les toutes les réunions que l'on doit
faire pour prendre des décisions pour
les changéens bas dans l'os dans le
salon d'accueil pour nos salariés
nécessite des heures de travail de
préparation pour aller pour aller
apporter des modifications
substantielles en faveur de nos salariés
moi je propose qu'à une chose qui est
très simple dans le code du civil il ya
un article du chef d'entreprise est très
important et pour les avocats et pour
les juristes aussi et qui lartigue à mon
avis le plus important de tout le code
concilie ses articles 134 et eddy quoi
et en 3 alinéa est dit que les
conventions légalement formées entre les
parties
yann eliés de quel lieu de loi à ceux
qui les ont formés en une phrase on a
tout dit tard qu'en fait quand on écrit
nous quelque chose avec un salarié c'est
doit être beaucoup plus fort que tout
leur est beaucoup plus fort que la loi
oui mais sa simple simplement quand on
quand on dit qu'ensuite elles ne peuvent
pas être révoqué sauf construite
mutuelle nous sauf le les cas que la loi
autorise et elles doivent été exécutées
de bonne foi je crois qu'avec ça ça
suffit largement à partir du moment où
avec un salarié ou avec l'ensemble de
nos représentants syndicaux on met des
choses en place ça doit être très
largement au delà au delà du raté est ce
qu'on en fait ce qu'on demande tout
simplement c'est s'il vous plaît foutez
nous la paix laissez nous travailler
laissez nous embaucher et je vous jure
que la croissance va repartir et
simplement
article 1 du code du nouveau code du
travail
foutez nous la paix si ça c'est pas ça
c'est au moins les français vont
comprendre c'est 3